I think key to Improv is always
listening to embracing it's positivity,
it's hearing things and not shutting
them down.
It's trying to find ways to make them
work and I think in the business world,
I would imagine that's very valuable.
The idea that it's very frustrating to
be told no all the time.
Improv really revolves around the idea
of like whatever you come at me with,
I'm going to say yes to it.
That's our reality.
Let's get to work.
Let's start there.
So just the idea of saying yes to each
other,
not shutting down ideas,
seeing if there's ways to make ideas
workable,
making that your default setting of
like,
I really want to respect what you're
saying.
See if there's a way to take it
somewhere else versus here's all the
things that are wrong with it.
Think it's just a very positive
mentality.
So I think a lot of people that come
across it get very addicted to it
because it does feel different.
Especially as a New Yorker.
We're just used to a world where
everybody's kind of grumpy all the time
and moving fast.
They don't want to deal with each other.
The idea of showing any emotion in
public,
not good,
the idea of slowing down to deal with
someone else's ideas and emotions.
Not Good.
Like we're New Yorkers.
We want to get where we're going.
So I think Improv really looks at a side
of life that's like,
well,
what if we let all that go for a little
while and just really work on sort of
positively embracing each other's ideas
and,
and uh,
and really listening hard to what other
people have to say.
So it's a pretty beautiful thing when
it's going right.
Very often what you'll see happen and
improv classes when people get nervous
about how it's going is they'll start
saying,
hey,
when,
uh,
when dad gets home,
he's going to be really mad.
Or they'll say like,
hey,
when we get to reno,
stuff's really going to hit the fan.
And they start saying like,
hey,
this thing that's going to happen,
or this thing,
hey,
remember when you did that thing back
then?
I'm really mad about it.
I think one of the things about
listening is that it's always at it's
most powerful when it's present,
when it's right here,
when it's right now,
and that's been a lesson about Improv
that I think just made me a much more
social person.
Like it just made me like when I would
go have pitch meetings,
I was just able to have it better.
Even in my personal life,
like I was just.
I got when I,
when I started really thinking hard
about these improv lessons,
not to get weird,
but like my dating life just got so much
better because the,
the thing I always stress that I think
apply just any conversation,
I always ask people to answer these
three questions when they're
improvising.
Why these people?
Why right here,
why right now?
I always just drill that why these
people?
Why right here,
why right now?
Meaning if you're not just.
If you're in a scene and there's two
people and you're talking about people
who aren't here like they're not here,
they probably aren't the most
interesting thing for an audience to
hear about.
If you're talking about a different
location than the scene,
the scenes taking place in,
then why isn't the scene unfolding
there?
It sounds more interesting.
Why are you teasing an audience?
So and another thing too,
people will often go like,
hey,
you'll never believe what's inside this
briefcase.
And it's like,
well that's invisible.
Let's just talk to each other us things.
We can find common ground,
whether that's positive things,
disagreements we might actually have.
Why are these people in this location at
this time?
Why isn't this the scene where choosing
to show the audience so the more we can
just make things present between the
people right there,
the less the audience has to suspend
their disbelief and imagine the better
the listening is going to be and the
harder it's going to hit.
And what we find when that happens in
Improv is your simple choices can
actually get huge reactions because if
you and I were doing a scene and I came
at you and start at the scene by saying,
you know what,
like everything that happened in Canada,
we can never talk about it again.
That sounds like it has really high
stakes,
but now the audience has to figure out,
well what happened in Canada and why are
we all scared of it?
Whereas if I just looked at you and
said,
hey,
I'm so scared and I need you to help me
through it.
That sounds like a more vague thing with
less comedic potential,
but an audience that they're scared and
you have to help each other.
Why?
Why are they scared?
They're scared right now and they can
help each other.
Great,
and it's a human connection that we can
latch onto,
so being present in the moment with each
other.
Nothing else you're going to work out.
It's gonna.
Make your improv scene so much better.
I feel it makes a lot of conversations
better to.
I'm a really big fan lately of the
phrase slow as slow,
as fast,
slow as fast,
and what I mean by that is like,
especially in the context I can,
I can speak to it in the context of
people who
go on stage,
which is like we forget that when we're
on stage and we're improvising and we're
bouncing ideas back and forth and
audience,
it's really hard for them to keep up and
they don't really know why we're making
the choices we're making because we're
trained in this and we have classes in
this so we can go.
So that to.
To them it looks like it's moving a
million miles an hour.
Like most people when they see an Improv
show,
if they like it,
they remember that first one is being
like the best show they ever saw and it
probably wasn't.
It's probably just that these people
knew what they were doing.
So much.
So one of the things I always like to
stress about slowing down,
slowing down,
slowing down is this idea.
It's actually something that I learned
from my wife uses this phrase because
she is an aerialist shit.
Her,
she was an aerialist for many years.
She was a dancer who would do all this
work with harnesses and rigging and
flying around from the ceiling and she
told me that phrase and it's stuck in my
head because she always said like,
if you have a problem with your harness,
you want to get it fixed fast so you can
go back to the the act you want to get
back in there.
But remember to the people watching like
no matter how long it takes,
no matter how slowly move,
you're still flying around in the sky.
And I think for Improv that really
applies well.
If like no matter how we can really take
a breath,
the audience is going to be blown away
if we do our jobs right.
We don't need to move fast to impress
them like the,
the desires.
Just joke,
joke,
laugh,
laugh at that.
But you can smother it.
So another thing I often say about it
too is like we have to remember when
we're improvising that like it's sort of
like building a fire,
like you have to start with the kindle
and you have to start with just a spark
and you can't just throw the big logs
on.
If you just try to pile everything on,
it's not going to go anywhere.
The audience is going to smell a rat.
I'm not going to be with it.
So for me,
I think the advice I can give anyone is
just remember someone who is a
professional doing what they do at any
speed is probably going to blow away and
novice.
They're probably going to have total
control.
And when we rush,
we actually can give that away.
I think when we consciously take a
breath and slow down at demonstrates
like confidence and mastery of our
craft,
which I know is a very pretentious thing
to say,
but that's what I used to say to people
when I taught them in their improv
acting classes,
which can be kind of pretentious.
So that's the main thing is remember
what we do is impressive.
We don't need to speed through it
because they're going to be blown away
as long as we do it with integrity.